un enfant de la balle s'est fait la
belle à lui frappé ni vient de mourir à
l'âge de 64 ans cette première femme
clown avait transmis sa passion du
cirque là plusieurs générations devant
les députés socialiste lionel jospin
s'explique sur le dossier vilvorde
la déprime se confirme pour les
constructeurs automobile les
immatriculations ont chuté de plus de
30% en juin
depuis hier minuit hong kong est devenu
une région administrative spéciale de la
république populaire de chine
page spéciale dans ce journal avec nos
envoyés spéciaux
madame monsieur bonsoir annie fratellini
vient de quitter définitivement la piste
à l'âge de 64 ans héritière du plus
célèbre trio de l'histoire du cirque
annie fratellini avait transmis sa
passion à plusieurs générations d'élèves
en fondant en 74 avec son mari pierre et
ex l'école nationale du cirque aux
machines et caroline landry une bouille
ronde un large sourire des yeux rieurs
l'image d'annie fratellini
c'est cette bille de clown sous un
chapeau melon des questions d'enfants
qui me demandait ça mange quoi un clown
sa vie comment ai je ne sais pas quoi
leur répondre en fait parce que je
n'avais pas envie de leur dire qu'un
clown était quelqu'un comme un autre
difficile d'échapper au monde du cirque
lorsque chez les fratellini on est clean
depuis quatre générations
dès l'âge de 6 ans elle apprend toutes
les disciplines sous l'autorité d'un
père exigeant mais à 20 ans elle ne
supporte plus ce carcan trop rigide elle
ne rêve que de théâtre elle deviendra
chanteuse de jazz danseuse de claquettes
puis comédienne
fait sa rencontre avec pierre et ex est
déterminante
ils ne rêvent que de cirque et lui faire
découvrir et apprécier ses racines il
sera le clown blanc
elle sera son auguste femmes ensemble
ils vont créer en 75 la première école
du cirque occidental elle ouvre à tous
les portes d'un monde jusqu'à présent
mythique à travers la technique elle
apprend aux enfants tout une discipline
de vie
la persévérance la rigueur ce que
c'était que le cirque que c'était du
travail
si le travail de tous les jours de
longue haleine pour arriver à une petite
chose comme ça il faut travailler des
mois et des mois connaît la passion du
cirque au oui
ils m'ont donné beaucoup
sa maladie elle l'a fixé droit dans les
yeux depuis des années de sa mort elle
en parle avec franchise
c'est vrai que je me prépare mieux je ne
lui était jamais préparé lundi j'ai
jamais mourir je pensais être immortel
et en fait c'est vrai qu'à partir d'un
moment je n'ai les choses en ordre
je voudrais pas de surprise par la mort
annie fratellini sans vent mais elle
laisse derrière elle un nouvel art du
cirque
d'autres vont prendre le relais et
continuer de faire rêver les grands
enfants que nous sommes
météo france prévoit à nouveau beaucoup
beaucoup de pluie pour demain
la situation ne devrait guère
s'améliorer avant la fin de cette
semaine
beaucoup de ceux et celles qu'on n'ose
plus appeler estivants voient leurs
vacances gâchées à la saint thierry
était pourri reportage du côté de dinard
olivier piou gabriel kenya mais où
peuvent donc bien être les touristes
voilà là non plus là encore - hélas pas
davantage pour les trouver les touristes
il faut aller tout simplement à l'office
du tourisme
car ce qui est bien en bretagne c'est
qu'il y à la mer mais ce qui émeut c'est
qu'il n'y a pas que la mer même si le
temps n'est pas tout à fait ce qu'on
souhaiterait qu'ils soient mais sans n'y
peut rien il ya quand même tellement de
choses à faire que ben les gens mon dieu
ne voit pas le temps trop passé et
reviendront sûrement quand même les
professionnels ne sont donc pas trop
inquiète en tout cas pas pour l'instant
les touristes n'ont pas déserté la
bretagne
loin de là tous ne sont même pas encore
arrivé ils se sont simplement organiser
et pour voir quand même la mer mais à
pied sec
rien de mieux qu'un aquarium géant celui
de saint-malo enregistre un taux de
fréquentation record depuis un mois le
temps n'y est pas pour rien n'est à
l'abri si à défaut d'avoir du soleil
bien on est à l'abri
on contemple quand même quelque chose
d'intéressant s'appelait pour toute la
famille les enfants sont heureux nous on
y trouve notre compte
tout le monde est content mais chassez
le naturel il revient au galop et le
naturel de dinars c'est le soleil il
suffit que surgisse un rayon une
éclaircie une embellie pour
qu'immédiatement fleurissent les
châteaux de sable et les jeux de plage
attention quand même ce serait trop bête
de se casser une jambe dès le premier
jour des vacances alors que la bourse de
paris frappé par la fièvre acheteuse
vole de record en record avec un cac40 à
2944 points aujourd'hui en hausse de 3%
sur la seule séance de ce mardi
c'est au contraire la déprime qui se
confirme pour tout le secteur automobile
avec une chute de plus de 30 % des
immatriculations en juin
l'ubs à 6 1 tous les chiffres annoncent
une année noire dans le secteur
automobile depuis janvier seuls 7 185
1000 voitures neuves ont trouvé preneur
avec un record pour le mois passé
une chute de plus de 30% le plus mauvais
mois de juin depuis 1962 qui clôt un
premier semestre désastreux -23% en fait
les constructeurs paient aujourd'hui
leur succès d'hier les primes
gouvernementales avaient dopé le marché
de nombreux clients avait alors anticipé
leurs achats d achat qu ils n'ont donc
plus de raison d'effectuer à présent
notre part le consommateur ne considère
plus la voiture comme un bien de
consommation mais comme un
investissement auquel il réfléchit à
fois préfèrent acheter autre chose
peut-être partir en vacances s'achetait
d'autres d'autres bien renouveler leur
voiture qui fonctionne bien et il pense
pouvoir la conserver un petit peu plus
longtemps
résultat pour la première fois les
constructeurs revoient à la baisse leurs
prévisions de ventes pour l'année il
envisageait un recul d'environ 10%
il table maintenant sur une chute de
plus de 15% les constructeurs français
perdent des clients sur leur propre
terrain à peine 55 % de parts de marché
contre un peu plus de 62% il ya deux ans
dans ce contexte renault comme psa ont
annoncé des plans sociaux pour réduire
les coûts et être plus compétitifs au
coeur d'une concurrence de plus en plus
difficile et les députés socialistes ont
demandé aujourd'hui l'organisation d'un
débat sur l'avenir de l'industrie
automobile
auparavant le groupe socialiste avait
entendu lionel jospin s'expliquer
précisément sur le dossier vilvorde
d'une manière générale le premier
ministre a rappelé les élus du ps aux
réalités économiques et à la discipline
majoritaire sur place guilaine chenu et
françoise david
premier rendez-vous première mise au
point à l'assemblée à huis clos devant
les députés socialistes un patient est
déjà turbulent lionel jospin planches
c'est contre l'opposition revancharde et
droitiser qu'il faut mener le combat à
celle premier ministre et non contre le
gouvernement exemple renault vilvorde
lionel jospin affirme qu'il n'a pas
renier ses engagements le dossier était
trop engagé il s'est avéré que la
solution qui consisterait à appliquer
par exemple sur le site de vilvorde
la réduction du temps de travail ne
pouvait pas suffire à régler le problème
deuxième mise au point un peu plus tard
à matignon
cette fois tous les parlementaires de
gauche sont invités en quelques mots
lionel jospin plaide pour le débat mais
aussi pour la solidarité
le chemin est étroit dit il la majorité
doit déblayer la route
message compris mais chacun garde ses
libertés quand ça ne va pas nous disons
et nous disons avec force est la
suivante ça ne va pas et nous voulons
faire autrement et nous proposerons de
faire autrement
mais il n'est pas question de poser le
problème de la participation des comices
au gouvernement aujourd'hui une heure
plus tard pour les députés et sénateurs
pressé de mettre en oeuvre le changement
c'est la non du calendrier parlementaire
texte sur l'emploi des jeunes
la priorité des priorités loi contre
l'exclusion sur le droit de la
nationalité
le message de soutien au gouvernement et
répétez l'exercice du pouvoir ne sera
pas solitaire mais pour le coup il doit
être solidaire en fin d'après-midi les
socialistes se retrouvent entre eux
dernière explication de la journée
l'ailé gauche du ps minoritaires reste
critique
la solidarité ne signifie pas que nous
soyons devenus des béni oui oui nous le
serons jamais en réunion ce sont les
anciens qui tente de tempérer les
ardeurs des plus jeunes
en suivant un peu juste
on peut attendre la rentrée enfin c'est
comme ça fin d'une journée de mise au
point et deux maîtres mots
la solidarité et le rythme
lionel jospin qui sera l'invité du
journal de france 2 jeudi à 20h pour un
premier bilan un mois après son entrée
en fonction le bureau du groupe rpr de
l'assemblée a qualifié d' initiative
regrettable le dîner qui a réuni il ya
quinze jours dans un restaurant parisien
entre autres le député rpr robert
pandraud et jean marie le pen au delà de
cet épisode les relations futures entre
les parties droite et le front national
trouble pas mal l'opposition le point
tout de suite en compagnie de roland
sicard et michaël darmon l'endroit
n'avait rien de secret un restaurant du
15e arrondissement plutôt classique où
les clients ont vu dinh et le 16 juin
dernier robert pandraud et jean marie le
pen
certains avaient même cru apercevoir
jean françois mancel
mais l'ancien secrétaire général du rpr
à démentent un dîner qui montre que des
contacts existent robert pandraud était
aujourd'hui injoignable pour en parler
d'autres font moins de mystère exemple
jacques limouzy élus dans le tarn avec
le soutien du front national et qui ne
s'en est jamais caché chaque chorale les
voix qu'elle soit est au calvaire
soit des rapprochements sur lesquels le
front national insiste lourdement le
parti d'extrême droite cherche depuis
longtemps des alliances effet sans
complexe son marché à l'assemblée
nationale il ya mon ami jacques limouzy
mais j'ai vu tout à l'heure allemande
d'alsace je pense qu'au tour de
jean-marie le chevallier un peu à peu
basses trait aux forains de ces pôle de
recomposition de la droite
des propos qui auraient rpm agace le
parti gaulliste qui tiendra dimanche ces
assises a décidé de réagir sans attendre
et c'est pour qu'on donne sont des
initiatives à caractère personnel qui
saute tout à fait regrettable
notre mouvement politique s'est
positionné de façon très claire dans
cette situation et il ne faut pas
confondre la position de l'électorat qui
manifeste la sambre de choses et des
discussions avec des cadres du front
national qui ne sont pas fréquentables
le rpr fait donc bien la différence
entre les électeurs du front national
qu'il veut reconquérir et les dirigeants
du parti qu'il rejette
philippe séguin a d'ailleurs décidé de
convoquer lundi robert pandraud au menu
sans doute une sévère mise en garde avec
le front national les dîners en ville ne
sont pas recommandés à aix en provence
le procureur a requis hier soir une
peine d'inégibilité à l'encontre de
catherine mégret maire front national de
vitrolles poursuivi pour diffamation à
caractère racial
les protestants de france ils sont
environ un million ont un nouveau chef
entre guillemets jean tartier succède à
jacques stewart à la présidence de la
fédération des protestants de france
premier président luthérien jean partiez
lui-même fils de pasteur est marié avec
une femme pasteur toni negri accusé dans
les années soixante dix d'être en
quelque sorte le cerveau l'idéologue des
brigades rouges est arrivé aujourd'hui à
rome après 13 ans d'exil à paris ce prof
de philo âgé de 64 ans condamné par
contumace à 12 ans de prison en italie a
été aussitôt arrêté par la police
antiterroriste reportage parce qu'elle
tous ces bons domique merlin
il n'aura pas fait le moindre pas en
liberté sur son sol natal comme prévu
toni negri 64 ans a été interpellé dès
son arrivée à l'aéroport de rome est
immédiatement conduit en prison
deux heures plus tôt à roissy charles de
gaulle
ce passage est si particulier ne se
faisaient aucune illusion sur son sort
il avait préparé ses effets personnels
le futur prisonniers pour l'été en
prison sourire convivialité du dernier
café de la liberté
le professeur de philosophie l'ami
d'althusser veut donner à son retour en
italie
toutes les apparences de la sérénité
toni negri n'est ni plus ni moins qu'une
figure mythique dans son pays
considérait à tort ou à raison comme
l'idéologue des brigades rouges groupe
terroriste d'extrême gauche 1978 les
brigades rouges justement lève et
assassine le chrétien-démocrate aldo
moro en italie le choc est immense
s'ensuivent des lois et des procès
d'exception
la presse italienne appelle cette époque
les années de plomb vingt-quatre mille
personnes sont jugées dont toni negri
condamné à 12 ans de prison comme
instigateur d'actions terroristes mais
il a pris la fuite vers paris 14 ans
d'exil qui prennent fin aujourd'hui
parce que lui et lui seul l'a décidé
c'est un acte politique n'est gratuit
rien mais pousse à sortir de france
rien sinon sa volonté d'accélérer le
vote d'une loi d'amnistié negri ce qu'il
n'effectuera qu'une petite partie de sa
peine
mais qu'importe on ne quitte pas si
facilement la liberté j'aurais bien pris
j'ai le livre et ses 14 ans ont été très
riches avec ultime regret d'un
philosophe avant son interpellation
toni negri dormira ici ce soir à la
prison de rebibbia les pronostics sur la
durée de son incarcération sont plus que
varier de un mois à 2 ans en fait
son sort est entre les mains d'une
commission indépendante de magistrats
tant que l'italie n'aura pas voté la loi
d'aministie elle n'en aura pas tout à
fait terminé avec ses années de plomb
lendemain de contestation en albanie
après les législatives anticipées qui
ont vu la victoire des anciens
communistes contestation venus notamment
du roi autoproclamé d'albanie les cas
premier qui affirme que le référendum
organisé parallèlement sur le retour à
un système de monarchie parlementaire a
été truqué au portage de nous on est
spéciaux philippe rochot jacques grilles
d'or ça n'est pas les vacances mais le
départ des 500 observateurs européens
après le premier tour des élections
mission accomplie mais scrutin contesté
par les démocrates de sali berisha qui
demande que l'on annuler les résultats
dans 30 zone des incidents et des
irrégularités
il y en a eu comme ici où les électeurs
étaient deux dans l'isoloir
ce qui est interdit mais pour les
observateurs cela ne suffit pas pour
remettre en cause la victoire des
socialistes
pires ne s'est pas produit il ya eu un
réflexe de sérieux de dignité de fierté
sans doute de la part du pape et
albanais mais les albanais étaient aussi
invités à voter pour ou contre la
monarchie et c'est la qibla colère les
royalistes le roi en tête estiment qu'on
a fait disparaître deux cent mille
bulletins qui lui aurait donné la
victoire
pourquoi si vous contestez les résultats
de ces attentats auraient été mal épilé
d'une place on est pourtant les cas fils
du roi zope premiers revenus en albanie
après 50 ans d'exil et est persuadé que
son pays allait devenir une monarchie
constitutionnelle mais les vainqueurs
d'aujourd'hui les socialistes ne veulent
pas ou n'en veulent plus le seul souci
des nouveaux maîtres de tirana et de
faire partir sans violence le président
albanais des élections qui ont donné
lieu à toute une série d'incidents
visant des journalistes étrangers
présents sur place
notre équipe notamment été violemment
molesté et notre reporter d'image à
grigor légèrement baissé plusieurs
équipes de télévisions étrangères ont vu
leur matériel détruit depuis hier minuit
heure locale
hong kong est donc devenue une région
administrative spéciale de la république
populaire de chine et 4000 hommes de
l'armée république populaire de
libération ont fait leur entrée ce matin
à l'aube sur l'ancien territoire
britannique
retour sur cet événement en compagnie de
nous on est spéciaux tout de suite nous
retrouvons en direct d'hong kong
daniel bilalian bonsoir si l'on commence
par l'anecdotique et bien la première
conséquence du retour de hong kong à
l'art à la chine aura été et bien deux
feux d'artifice géant dans la baie de
hong kong
le premier avait été offert par les
anglais c'était hier soir le second par
le nouveau gouvernement il vient de se
terminer à l'instant deux feux
d'artifice donc en 48 heures ajoutez à
cela quatre jours fériés pour une
population qui a plutôt ici l'habitude
de travailler 24 heures sur 24
reportage bernard lebrun roger la ville
la plus scintillante du bout du
parce que la plus riche aux gratte-ciel
transformer en arbre de noël
la perle de l'orient comme on l'appelle
a conclu sa première journée dans le
giron de la chine par un extravagant son
et lumière cadeau de paix qu'a aussi
million et demi d'habitants d'hong kong
pour fêter leur retour à la mère patrie
financé par les riches milliardaires pro
chinois est réalisé par des américains
deux millions de personnes s'étaient
massées autour de la baie pour profiter
du grandiose feu d'artifice tiré
diapason d'un orchestre symphonique
peach et 75 millions de francs
m
spectacle se devait de surpasser celui
donné la veille au même endroit pour la
cérémonie des adieux des colonisateurs
britanniques
il fallait prendre date en restituant à
la ville la plus moderne l'extrême
orient
la tradition chinoise avec cette
flottille de papiers cartons
certains ont déjà perçu une forme de
concession esthétique
d'autres ne sont pas venus opposants
démocrates en tête pour ne pas faire de
concessions politiques
ce matin hong kong reprendra le travail
et sa marche en avant
la fête est finie la co existence
commence avec le pouvoir chinois
après les festivités officielles d'hier
soient et de ce soir encore vous venez
de les voir effectivement la première
manifestation tangible de la présence
chinoise ici à hong kong c'est l'armée
4000 hommes de troupe qui sont arrivé
par les airs par bateau et aussi par
camion de la frontière entre hong kong
et la chine ils ont pris la place dans
les casernes des soldats britanniques
qui étaient partis la veille au soir
c'est un geste politique fort adressé au
monde les états unis l'angleterre l'ont
bien compris qui ont boudé les premières
festivités du nouveau gouvernement de
hong kong geste politique fort également
destinée à la chine puisque ces hommes
qui sont arrivés ici
marc que cette rétrocession n'est pas
simplement je dirais vulgairement la fin
d'un bail commercial de 99 ans mais une
reconquête conquête pacifique certes
mais reconquête tout de même d'un
morceau important du territoire chinois
reportage jérôme ni bernard houle
l'histoire en marche et les hong kong
est qui la regardent passer ce matin dès
l'aube l'armée populaire de libération
reprend possession de la colonie
britannique à l'appel du comité de
quartier les riverains sont tombé du lit
au venir acclamer les nouveaux maîtres
du territoire des militaires à la tête
remplie de leur mission
laver l'affront infligé par les
britanniques lors des guerres de l'opium
au 19e siècle
cent cinquante ans de contrôle colonial
gong
je voulais voir les soldats leur
souhaiter la bienvenue et admirer la
puissance de l'europe
d'autres langues kong et se sont émus de
voir surgir ces blindés rappelant ceux
de la répression du mouvement de
tiananmen en 1989
mais ce contingent de 4500 hommes ne
touchera pas aux questions de sécurité
publique
il vient simplement affirmé le
changement de souveraineté sur hong kong
de la façon la plus voyante sur terre
comme en mer
pour montrer que le jour j tant attendu
par pékin est enfin arrivé à l'état
major du régiment du prince de galles
les hong kong et découvre une relève de
la garde d'un nouveau speed c'est mieux
comme ça personne ne peut l'ignorer
ce 1er juillet hong kong n'est plus ce
qu'elle était l'homme qui a été désigné
par pékin pour assurer cette transition
douce de hong kong vers la chine
s'appelle tu chantes tu vois il a prêté
serment quelques heures à peine après le
départ des britanniques c'était la nuit
dernière ici à hong kong devant le
premier ministre chinois
monsieur libère l'homme chante joie et
un jeune homme de 60 ans il est
milliardaire il est armateurs sa famille
avait fui la chine communiste c'était
dans les années 1900 mais 49
et pourtant c'est lui qui a été désigné
par pékin pour assurer cette transition
sa première décision ce matin était de
réduire quelque peu les libertés en
réduisant par exemple droit de
manifestation mais en même temps il a
annoncé des élections démocratiques at
il dit c'est pour 1998 à voir il y avait
des manifestations ce soir à hong kong
ce magnifique feu d'artifice
manifestations encore plus géante à
pékin comme on sait les organiser là-bas
dans le plus grand stade de la ville on
avait réuni des centaines de milliers de
spectateurs
des centaines de milliers de danseurs
pour une fête qui n'avait rien de
spontané reportage
isabelle bechler tristan le bras au
début le spectacle du stade des ouvriers
pékin figurer la lutte de la chine
contre l'impérialisme comprenez contre
la grande-bretagne et les autres
puissances occidentales au siècle
dernier qui à coups de traités inégaux
se sont alliées des concessions en chine
il est question de l'humiliation
nationale de trahison de faiblesse de
ruines de honte les aime qui rentrait de
route compte dont le président tient aux
mines le faisait justement la tête car
il venait de laver l'honneur chinois aux
dépens du colonisateur britannique
caressant le nationalisme des chinois
dans le sens du poil
ça va donner l'exemple d'un retour en
douceur pour macao et préparer le
règlement final de la question
taïwanaise
la petite île perdue qui réclame sa
maman dans les ruines pourrait bien être
macao
en attendant taiwan du mois les plus
hardis ne se priveront pas de l'évoquer
à la mesure du triomphalisme du jour
grande éloquence et autosatisfaction la
chine populaire a manifestement le
sentiment d'avoir remporté une très très
grande victoire pour mettre en scène
cette joie d'un morceau de patrie
retrouver la capitale chinoise a mis les
petits plats dans les grands
on a fait danser près de dix mille
artistes pour 80 mille invités triés sur
le volet parfois venus de l'étranger
on va gagner plus d'argent qu'on pourra
voyager je pourrais les encombre pour
voir moi aussi ce qui se passe là bas je
suis vraiment impressionné qu'ils aient
réussi à monter un si beau spectacle
ça me fait chaud au coeur cette
réunification après on compte ce sera la
réunification avec taïwan et macao
prochaine occasion de réjouissance
réunification de macao décembre 99
hong kong est donc revenue ce soir dans
le giron de la chine mais pékin vous
l'avez entendu dans ce reportage n'a pas
encore récupéré la totalité de son
territoire
il reste taiwan ça c'est une affaire
entre chinois et cet après midi dans ce
stade de pékin le président chinois a
proposé à taïwan le même régime qu'à
hong kong à savoir un seul pays la chine
le rattachement mais deux régimes
économiques comme entre eux hong kong et
pékin
et puis il ya macao là le problème est
réglé en 1999 et bien
officiellement les portugais rendront
macao à la chine reportage bernard
lebrun roger moore
le hasard et la nécessité
macao n'est pas l'enfer du jeu de la
chanson pour autant sans les casinos la
petite colonie portugaise de merde
chimie seraient au chômage
un tiers des 450 mille habitants qui
travaillent nuls survit grâce aux taxes
sur les paris photo souvenir devant le
temple du jeu et les ruines des églises
coloniale et touristes sont chinois
malaisien philippe wang un passé très
européen et un présent très asiatique
il y a quatre cent quarante ans mais
jésuites et les soldats de l'infante
débarquer this terre de mission et de
commerce
macao fut ruiné par l'essor d'un conte
aujourd'hui 90% des habitants sont
chinois la chine tout proche ici de
l'autre côté de la rivière des perles
c'est tout le devenir de macao à son
tour en 1999 elle sera rattachée au
continent alors cette porte historique
qui séparait le monde s'ouvrira le jour
de noël
c'est le seul symbole du convoi
portugais qui disparaître des
négociations sont en cours en possible
durant 15 ans l'issue un échange rien à
macao ils l'ont promis déjà les sociétés
chinoises de canton et celle implantée à
hong kong multiplie les investissements
immobiliers pour préparer le transfert
de leurs sociétés et les casinos que
deviendront-ils avenue mario soares au
palais du gouverneur ont négocié leur
survie
c'est shy la chine accepte pas le jeu il
nous sera très difficile de ratifier les
accords pour l'instant les chinois
disent que la tradition industrielle du
divertissement propre à macao
continueront les casinos sont interdits
en chine
mais ce que redoute pékin ce ne sont pas
tant les jeux d'argent que la
criminalité qui l'entourent avec sa
guerre des gangs
la petite île est le grand pays sont en
pleine négociation pour savoir si demain
makau rimera toujours avec casino voilà
après deux jours de festivités la vie va
reprendre maintenant à hong kong reste à
savoir si les accords qui ont été signés
officiellement ici seront respectés ça
eh bien c'est l'avenir qui nous liera à
vendre ou non merci
bon retour toujours dans l'actualité à
l'étranger cette information encore au
conditionnel en algérie un imposant
dirigeants du gia
radwan n'a cadors se seraient ralliés
aux autorités en leur livrant des
informations confidentielles sur
l'organigramme et sur les maquis du gia
radwan mac adore figurait avec l'actuel
chef du gia en tard à warri
parmi les islamistes dont la tête était
mise à prix sur des affiches placardées
sur les murs d'alger
d'autre part anouar haddam l'un des
dirigeants du front islamique du salut
actuellement incarcérés en virginie
devrait être mise en examen cette
semaine par un juge d'instruction
français venus spécialement aux
etats-unis mise en examen aux chefs
d'association de malfaiteurs en relation
avec une entreprise terroriste
le 9 juin 91 à mantes-la-jolie une femme
policier de 32 ans a trouvé la mort
après avoir été renversée par une
voiture volée qui forçait un barrage
le jeune marocain qui était au volant
est jugé depuis hier par la cour
d'assises des yvelines
reportage valérie ermite hervé pozzo
adjibi n'avait pas son permis de
conduire mais cette nuit du 8 au 9 juin
91 avec d'autres ses copains il prendra
le volant d'une voiture volée pour se
rendre à une fête à mantes la jolie
pris en chasse par des policiers alsaidi
tombe sur un autre véhicule de police
qui lui fait barrage saïdi décide alors
de forcer le passage mais au dernier
moment
marie-christine bayer sort du véhicule
de police le choc est extrêmement
violent
la jeune femme policier meurt de ses
blessures
hazard est morte en tant que policier
parce qu'elle représentait le dernier
rempart de la légalité dans des zones
que l'on appelle de non droit où
d'extraterritorialité tornos est mort
accidentelle c'est tout il n'a pas fait
volontairement tu es un accident
s'éteindra malheureusement c'est tout
mais il a payé il a fait cinquante
quatre mois ferme et aujourd'hui on
rentre alyssa comme si c'était des
jeunes
j'ai des jeunes bandits qu'ils veulent
avec des véhicules faire la guerre en
policier cpo al zaïdi a déjà fait quatre
ans et demi de détention préventive
il encourt 20 ans de réclusion
criminelle dans la salle de la cour
d'assises des yvelines
de nombreux policiers bien sûr mais
également des jeunes des banlieues venue
rappeler que deux des leurs sont morts
aussi à mantes la jolie
durant ce printemps 91 l'un dans un
commissariat suite à une crise d'asthme
l'autre
la même nuit que marie-christine beillé
tué d'une balle dans la nuque par l'un
des coéquipiers de la jeune femme
policier jean michel boucheron a été
condamné aujourd'hui à quatre ans de
prison dont deux ans ferme et al houdoud
flamande incarcéré en france depuis le
25 mars l'ancien maire socialiste
d'angoulême poursuivi pour corruption et
ingérence entre autres a été également
privé de ses droits civiques pour cinq
ans le parquet avait requis quatre ans
de prison ferme
d'autre part l'ancien vice président rpr
du conseil régional de l'essonne alain
jose a été condamné à deux ans de prison
dont un avec sursis il a déjà effectué
16 mois de prison préventive aux états
unis à cap canaveral décollage réussi
aujourd'hui ce soir pour l'alm et
sociales columbia pour une mission de 16
jours exclusivement consacrée à des
expériences scientifiques avec notamment
des expériences sur de la microgravité
ce vol de columbia est un fait une
répétition de la mission qui avait été
engagé au début du malgré la suite d'une
défaillance toujours dans l'espace la
collision mercredi dernier en plein ciel
entre un module de la station hôpital
russe mir et un vaisseau cargo progress
a provoqué des dégâts évalués à environ
18 millions de francs depuis cet
accident les trois occupantes de mire
deux russes et un américain évoluent
dans des conditions particulièrement
éprouvantes oxygène rationner
semi-obscurité ou encore chaleur et ouf
romuald de beaune en deux jours après la
première collision spatial de l'histoire
le sourire des trois cosmonautes est
encore un peu forcé même si le pire a
été évité
la vie à bord demeure plutôt angoissante
un module hors service des problèmes
d'énergie électrique de fabrication
d'oxygène et une humidité élevée qui
paralyse l'informatique
de quoi ébranler le moral des plus
solides alors pendant 12 à 18 mois les
cosmonautes s'entraîne en piscine ou en
simulateur pour réagir aux situations
les plus délicates incendie réparation
de fortune à bord et même retour sur
terre improvisé selon cet ancien
cosmonaute russe qui a lui-même été
confrontés à des incidents l'équipage a
réussi le plus difficile même le stress
choisir la solution qui répond au
problème
ce qui est loin d'être évident dans
l'espace il faut dire que les petits et
les gros pépins sont devenus le lot
quotidien des cosmonautes qui
rejoignirent près de 15 sans incident
technique en 11 ans des incidents qui
peuvent se transformer en catastrophe si
chaque équipage ne s'y prépare pas assez
rapide de réaction donc l'entraînement
l'envié et dans dix joueurs moselle dose
de stress une sortie dans l'espace pour
constater l'étendue des dégâts avec un
retour d'urgence à la moindre anomalie
aux internationaux de tennis de wingles
dont mary pierce e tête de série numéro
9 s'est fait couper l'herbe sous le pied
en se faisant éliminer par araxxe à à
sánchez vicario tête de série numéro 6
l'espagnol a dominé cette rencontre de
bout en bout score final 6 1 6 3 en
quarts de finale arantxa sanchez
rencontrera une autre française nathalie
tauziat qui s'est qualifiée tout à
l'heure aux dépens de sandrine testud
qui a laissé filer trois balles de match
était un match interrompu deux fois par
la pluie
chez les hommes cédric pioline s'est
qualifié pour les quarts de finale il
rencontrera un le britannique greg wood
est ce qu on a appris aujourd'hui le
suicide de jeudi dernier à paris de
l'actrice olga georges picot âgé de 53
ans après avoir commencé sa carrière en
posant pour des photos de mode
à l'âge de 17 ans il fait quelques
apparitions dans des téléfilms olga
georges picot avait fait ses vrais
débuts au cinéma grâce à un arrêt n'est
que lui avait offert le premier rôle
féminin de son film je t'aime je t'aime
ensuite olbia georges picot avait tourné
dans une vingtaine de films c'est claude
nougaro qui a donné hier soir le coup
d'envoi de la 17e édition du festival
jazz à vienne une des quatre principales
manifestations du genre en france avec
nice antibes et marcillac reportage
ouvriers de l'air christian tu
le garant à la démarche sancho et landon
ampli shot
souvent blessé mais chaque fois
ressources et il reprend le chemin de la
scène comme on entre dans l'arène
je forme mes puits de pétrole je crois
dans la dans le la substance de ma vie
je raconte finalement c'est mes chansons
plus ou moins ce qu'il s'agit bel et
bien d'une autobiographie
après deux ans de silence un pontage
coronarien
claude nougaro soffritti hier il ne lui
en cours pas moins le théâtre antique de
vienne et son festival de jazz
l'enfant d'un combat
le verbe haut et le swing dans le sang
le toulousain reste un alchimiste aura
capable d'emballer un public de tous
âges en chantant la femme le messie ou
la mort mais jamais
oui
dans le ventre du bonheur
on est
on est souvent de l'amant est ce que
vous avez le sentiment que le temps file
plus vite désormais oui ça fait beaucoup
c'est vrai c'est vrai elle l'arion
précipité à la fin des jours vers le
boulot finale gtoi petits dommages du
ciel l'appui et vtt pour les claquettes
juste assez pour accompagner les 9000
spectateurs venus au rendez vous je suis
son
par cerf et grave à la fois clown ungaro
s'engage avec une vigueur intacte sur le
parcours du coeur battant
sur les 2
nous avons commencé ce journal en
évoquant la disparition d'annie
fratellini en hommage à cet artiste je
vous propose de terminer cette édition
avec le clown beau gosse ceux qui
évoquent la mémoire de cet enfant de la
balle qui avait été la première femme à
faire l'auguste reportage frédéric dupuy
andrey germain est attaché beaucoup
d'importance à la poésie dans ses
spectacles dans tous les spectacles que
j'ai vu d'elle il y avait des moments
très très prenant très émotionnel elle
jouait le temps des cerises parce que ça
voulait dire quelque chose certainement
au plus profond d'elle-même par exemple
tout moment elle pourrait être aussi
bien dramatique pharmacien un sentiment
de tristesse comme elle le faisait quand
elle elle faisait le petit garçon ou la
petite fille puisqu'on ne savez j'ai pas
vraiment quelle est-elle sexe de deux
personnages au départ cas le véhicule
est comme ça
e
voilà dernier journal le vers 00h15 en
compagnie de florence dauchez demain 7
en cinq ans dans les 4 vérités
gérard leclerc recevra philippe vasseur
l'ancien ministre de l'agriculture
bonne fête aux thierry bon anniversaire
à lady diana 36 ans aujourd'hui dans un
instant la météo sophie davant toujours
beaucoup de pluie des pyrénées à
l'alsace ailleurs des averses et des
ongles à 13 heures patrick chêne j'aurai
le plaisir de vous retrouver à 20h très
très bonne soirée
continue